most skydivers jump off a plane flying
3.8 kilometers above the ground but
imagine jumping off something even
higher like the International Space
Station unless you have a super suit
like Tony Stark
it's not gonna end well but let's
pretend Ironman lends you one okay ready
three two one jump wait what
that's right you won't fall straight
down in fact it'll take you at least two
and a half years before you reach the
surface so what's going on
height isn't the main reason your fall
takes so long in fact if you felt like a
normal skydiver it would only take you
about 2 hours but the thing is you don't
fall straight down you fall into orbit
the reason is speed you see the ISS
might be called the station but it's
hardly stationary it's actually moving
12 times faster than a jet fighter if
you shot anything at that speed on earth
by the time it was about to hit the
ground it would miss in the same way the
ISS isn't floating in space it's falling
towards Earth and missing and when you
jump off the ISS you're initially moving
at the same speed so you end up in orbit
- at least for a while now even though
it's so high up the ISS is pushing
through a very thin atmosphere so that
friction against the atmosphere slows it
down so the station fires engines to
maintain speed and keep from crashing
into the earth but sadly your super suit
doesn't come with engines strapped to
your feet this has two consequences
first it means you can't maneuver and
have to hope that any of those 13,000
chunks of space debris
don't impale you second without rockets
to maintain your speed it'll slow you
down and spiral toward Earth but it
won't be quick the Chinese Space Station
Geumgang one for example took about two
years to fall out of orbit on the ISS
you're higher up so you'll take roughly
two-and-a-half years but once you strike
the atmosphere your long wait is over
and it's go time as Yuri enter you have
one goal slow down you're travelling at
hypersonic speeds so if you deploy a
parachute now it'll shred to pieces and
that's not the only
falling through the atmosphere at such
breakneck speeds generates at least
eight G's of force that's eight times
the gravity you feel at sea level end if
you're falling feet first that'll push
the blood away from your brain and
toward your feet so you'll probably pass
out unless you're one of those fighter
pilots who trained withstand up to 5 G's
now if you don't pass out you may worry
about the freezing temperatures up here
but it turns out your suits more likely
to melt than freeze you know how you
could warm your hands by rubbing them
together now imagine your super suit
rubbing against air molecules in the
atmosphere at least six times the speed
of sound
you'll heat up to about 1,650 degrees
Celsius hot enough to melt iron in fact
the heat is so intense it strips
electrons from their atoms forming a
pink plasma around you that will
ultimately destroy your suit if that's
not enough of a problem the drag will
rip off your limbs but thankfully Tony
Stark has your back and somehow your
super suit holds with you intact at 41
kilometers up you've now reached the
world record for highest sky dive in
2014
Alan Eustace wore a pressurized
spacesuit as he wrote a balloon up to
this height he broke the sound barrier
on his way down before deploying his
parachute and landed about 15 minutes
after the drop but you'll be falling
much faster than Eustace
about three times the speed of sound so
in reality you're not going to slow down
enough to safely deploy your chute
that's where Ironman can help us one
last time by one kilometer up
you've reached the territory of ordinary
skydivers who don't need fancy suits to
survive at this point your parachute can
do what it does best and it's finally
time to land softly whoo what a ride
what sort of daring feat would you want
us to try next let us know in the
comments below and thanks for watching